our first learning algorithm will be
linear regression in this video you see
what the model looks like and more
importantly you also see what the
overall process of supervised learning
you'll flip let's use a motivating
example of predicting housing prices
we're going to use a data set of housing
prices from the city of Portland Oregon
and you're going to plot my data set of
a number of houses there were different
sizes that were so for a range of
different prices let's say that given
this data set you have a friend that's
trying to sell a house and let's see
your friend's house is of size 1,250
square feet and you want to tell them
how much they might be able to sell the
house for well one thing you could do is
fit to a model maybe put a straight line
to this data then write something like
that and based on that maybe you could
tell your friend that looks likely to
maybe sell the whole square around to
$18,000 so this is an example of a
supervised learning algorithm and it's
supervised learning because we're given
the quote right answer for each of our
examples namely were told what was the
actual house what was the actual price
that each of the houses in our data set
was so for and moreover does an example
of a regression problem where the term
regression refers to the fact that we're
predicting a real-valued output maybe
the price and then just remind you the
other type the other most common type of
supervised learning problem is called
the classification problem where we
predict discrete values outputs such as
if we are looking at cancer tumors and
trying to decide if a tumor is malignant
or benign so there's a 0 1 value
distrito more formally in supervised
learning we have a data set and this
data set is called a training set so for
a housing price an example we have a
training set of different housing prices
and our job is to learn from this data
how to predict the prices of the houses
let's define some notation that we're
using throughout this course I'm going
to define quite a lot of symbols
is okay if you don't remember all the
symbols right now but as the course
progresses so be useful with a
convenient notation so I'm going to use
lowercase M throughout this course to
denote the number of training examples
so in this data set if I have you know
let's say 47 rows in this table then I
have 47 training examples and M equals
47 let me use lowercase X to denote the
input variables often also called the
features so though the X's here will be
on input features and I'm going to use Y
to denote my output variables or the
target variable region to predict its
Alexis second column here a little bit
more notation I'm going to use X comma Y
to denote a single training example so a
single row in this table corresponds to
a single training example and to refer
to a specific training example I'm going
to use this notation X I comma Y I and
going to use this to refer to the
training example so this superscript I
over here this is not exponentiation
right this X I Y I the superscript I in
parenthesis that's just an index into my
training set and it refers to the I row
in this table okay so this is not except
our of iy ^ I instead X I Y I just
refers to the I fro of this table so for
example X 1
you know refers to the input value for
the first training example so that's 21
0 4 represents X to the first row X 2
would be equal to 14 16 right the second
x and y 1 will be equal to 460 with
that's the first the Y value for my
first training example that's what that
one refers to
so as I mentioned occasionally I'll ask
you a question to let you check your own
understanding and a few seconds in this
video a multiple-choice question will
pop up in the video when it does please
use your mouse to select what you think
is the right answer
we're defined by the training set is and
so here's how a supervised learning
works we solve them of a training set
like our training set of housing prices
and we feed that to our learning
algorithm is the job of a learning
algorithm to then output a function
which by convention is usually denoted
lowercase H and H stands for hypothesis
and what the job of the hypothesis is is
is a function that takes as input the
size of a house like maybe the size of a
new house that your friend is trying to
sell it takes in a value of X and it
tries to output the estimated value of y
for their corresponding house so H is a
function that map's from X's to YS um
people often ask me you know why is this
function called a hypothesis some of you
may know the meaning of the term
hypothesis from the dictionary or from
signs or whatever it turns out that the
machine learning this is a name that was
used in the early days of machine
learning and this kind of stuff because
maybe not a great name for this sort of
function for mapping from sizes of
houses to the predictions but you know I
think the term hypothesis maybe isn't
the best possible name for this but is
what this is the standard terminology
that people using here you know so don't
worry do it don't worry too much about
why people call it that when designing a
learning algorithm the next thing we
need to decide is how do we represent
this hypothesis H for this in the next
few videos I'm going to choose our
initial choice for representing the
hypothesis will be the following going
to represent H as follows and with the
right of this subscript theta of x
equals theta 0 plus theta 1 of X and
as a shorthand sometimes instead of
writing you know H subscript theta of X
sometimes it's a shorthand I'll just
write this is H of X but more often our
rector the subscript theta over there
and plotting to some pictures all this
means is that we are going to you know
predict that Y is a linear function of X
right so there's a data set and what
this function is doing is just
predicting that Y is some straight line
function of X s of x equals 3 0 plus
theta 1 X ok and why a linear function
well sometimes we'll want to fit more
complicated perhaps nonlinear functions
as well but since this linear case is
the simple building block we'll start
with this example first so fitting
linear functions and we'll build on this
to eventually have more complex models
in more complex learning algorithms let
me also give this particular model a
name small though is called linear
regression or district example is a
actually linear regression with one
variable will be variable being X some
connecting housing prices functions in
one variable X and another name for this
model is you need the area linear
regression and you need area is just you
know a fancy way of saying one variable
so that's linear regression in the next
video we'll start to talk about just how
to go about implementing this model